here to present the musical score award
is lovely with our music only the
adapter is the one who's nominated if
the score is an adaptation from another
medium cool that's the rule
assuming that you did what I'd be laying
down so far now we're here to tell you
what the nominations are
goodbye mr. juice and have checked
production
Leslie brickest wrote the song the debt
and Peter sing Johnny Williams adapted
then and made the whole thing
darling Chanel productions 20th Century
Fox a turn and lion aluminum rose kenapa
racial attack did all the music and
denomination paint your wagon an alan
jay lerner production the hey diddle
diddle the cat and the fiddle were all
attempted by newsom sweet
Universal Pictures psych Holmen adapted
psych home and school it seems to me he
said those songs before they shoot
horses don't they
a rubber chart offer win Winkler Sydney
[ __ ] production ABC Pictures
presentation Cinerama - are you through
John Green and now but would bleed it
the adaptation
they split the credits but not the
we are sure
the winners are
Lenny hatin and Lionel Newman for Hello
Dolly
I know port noise complaint
Lenny ate and couldn't make night but
I'm sure he's just as gassed as I am and
I I do want to take this moment to thank
dick zanuck not only for this but for
everything is done for me and for Ernie
layman for being so goddamn beautifully
difficult and the sound and the
wonderful Orchestra at Fox I don't know
what the hell I'm saying but thank you
very much